I think they're taking a step back I was
very pleased that we were able to reach
agreement with several Health unions on
a fair and reasonable pay settlement for
about 1.4 million NHS workers it's right
that they're paid fairly and rewarded
for the Fantastic work they do whether
it's nurses midwives paramedics or
others but also important you know just
referring back to Harry's questions that
that was affordable for the taxpayer and
consistent with our promises the heart
of inflation and cut the waiting list
and I think we've dropped the right
balance and I think you would have seen
I hope the comments from the health
secretary today that did provide the
reassurance that people were looking for
and now of course there are always
conversations between departments in the
treasury that and I wouldn't want to get
in the middle of precisely by the health
sector Who provided strong reassurance
about additional funding as well as
re-prioritization from elsewhere but
making sure the commitment to continue
delivering care and all our commitment
to cut waiting lists there's absolutely
Paramount and protected and I think
that's been warmly welcomed by the
sector